now now now now in case we're live well
in a second it's got a stat take a
second receiving their content
okay we're good I think I think so yeah
any second now we'll start seeing people
hopping in the chat
this
I'll try to read the comments as they
come all right I still love this picture
so much of a Punisher just going and the
lighting is so crazy and all you can see
is like a faint reflection of his eyes
so yeah it's the scariest thing it's the
most threatening image cursed image I'm
gonna close this so we're not you know
killing my PC with a
right domine you went for a lot of
prototypes for the skull oh yeah those
all look good you know it's like that
that I look like that's you on the right
just giant but public here we go
now we're cooking with gas
like you mentioned before the paint
spilled on that shirt it was one of
those skulls I think like he
accidentally screwed it up like like he
was trying to paint the skull with the
the spray paint and then he just he just
holds it up and it's like that top right
one no it's the one that's scribbled out
it looks too cute
[Music]
hey chat oh people are starting to show
up in what are we gonna name our
high-end xmin what are we gonna name our
safe for help
[Applause]
most important question
I'm really hoping no one spoils oh god
no don't say that now they're gonna um
let's see what's that what's a good name
for our Punisher save file don't worry I
have not seen any of the show okay so
yeah it's kind of fun we're gonna start
the killing now I'm gonna try chargers
acutely dammit it's not enough letters
yes [ __ ] gonna start to kill
okay damn it damn it Andre
[Music]
you better have enough letters
ah okay
[Music]
it's like the most this is the hypest
gameplay all game volumes up a little
bit okay how's that everyone better
although the music got quiet right as I
turn it down soon like why not the best
indication damn it
should we wait here until the music gets
really intense again I mean we can we
can always just like pause methank Haley
I guess so anyway if people don't know
I'm streaming today with my buddy
Jackson you might know him from my
extremely old let's play series that no
one watched the my personal favorite was
the first yeah where we took a phone
camera oh yeah we've held a phone camera
up to five nights at freddys for several
minutes yeah a classic game yes
hey Diego yeah so that that let's ignore
series I still go back and watch that
sometimes and just giggle let the
stupidity of the things we've seen
we have excellent Leona overboard okay I
got it I got it
we have it did someone suggested I'm
gonna I have an idea
okay we'll be the spider-man
okay okay we're good I am John
spider-man all right what are we going
on uh like four we'll get through more
first dreams sake if we're uneasy yeah
well I love it but everyone's gonna be
mean and be like all you chose are
difficult oh you're on our to go on easy
exactly easy difficulty that's for
babies no we can't this m-rated game
where you shoot people in the face save
profile spider-man nice easy gets rid of
all the blood - what
yeah that's fact no I want the blood I
want all the blood all right opening
cutscene so we got a cinematic
opening cutscene is so goddamn cool
he's got one bullet in about eight
people
looks like some of you are gonna have to
share
he's Dhoni it's too afraid of him you
don't have to reload this knife the ones
who killed my family the Saints they've
given me a reason
oh yeah because this is technically in
the same pattern as the movie gangs
called the Saints yeah cuz John
Travolta's character was John's single
morning that's right oh yeah
hey Joey what did you get
it better be Lego Marvel - hey so um I
noticed that there's not a lot of people
showing up yet is it because I put the
joke title of disciplinarian like if I
actually put Punisher would people show
up should I do that you might be a good
idea okay I mean I don't know then my
people here are just put it in all
capitals and then misspelled Punisher or
the Punisher parentheses discipline oh
okay yes yes
[Music]
now let's do I'm just kidding about
disciplinarian
all right Xavier plays punish your ps2
late there you go okay
well you'd think the thumbnail would
bring people in because it's just a
picture of Punisher hiding around a
corner getting ready to shoot people and
it looks like the box art for it reminds
me of this thing on the back of the box
for Mass Effect one we're just Shepard
hiding around the corner with his gun
held up to his face and he's like he's
ready yes okay war zone the greatest
movie of all time remember that scene
were Punisher punches so hard in a guy's
face that his fist goes out like the
back of his head basically yeah he
punches some guy up against the door
jamb and just like just explodes his
head there's also a scene I think where
Punisher shoots a grenade out of
someone's hand and explodes him that
could be misremembering that the Mendoza
Nader
like that okay there's a crack house
near my apartment could use some kind
okay oh yeah add the midair rocket
launcher okay so there's a guy there's a
crime boss who does parkour and he's
always on like speed and there's a one
scene where they're like doing this like
it looked like it like a some kind of
music video from the 90s where they're
all hopping across rooftops and like
jumping around and then one guy tries to
do like a front flip over from one
rooftop to another and then a rocket
flies by and catches him in midair
before he lands and then he just blows
up and like the the happy-go-lucky music
that's like all excited just stops and
the rest of the guys are standing there
going what and then a Punisher kicks a
guy off a rooftop and he lands on a
fence post and then Punisher jumps and
then kicks that guy his head and then
breaks it and like decapitates him
internally
[Music]
alright let's just kill you hey thank
you the hyena effect that we're forever
on it uh who doesn't read descriptions
we're trying to raise money to get a
copy of lego marvel to since people have
been telling me that I should play that
game so so all the donations are
appreciated we're gonna we're gonna try
to make it they're gonna go for about
two commendations to you liking
I'm detective so lately I Castle how
many people have you killed in the last
few weeks not sure there were a lot of
explosions okay let's go back to the
beginning and see where the trail of
mangled bodies I'm not gonna hire a
black horrible I don't hire a video game
let's chat while we wait for him just
three weeks here on the neighborhood
crack house comics what excuse me Stevie
shows so those two are characters from
the 2000 I think it was 2001 or just
2000 but it was the series where
Punisher tried to be three isn't
interesting again after
[Music]
okay works and I was called welcome back
to New York
like I no one notices that he's the
Punisher like he's not the logo he looks
like he's going to but it's not real
there's nothing to help you Jean did a
really great job of the boys acting just
because the mayor know that this is a
flat the police kissed the the game
starts with him giving himself up after
a whole bunch of stuff and then they're
like how did you how did the last few
weeks go and he's like well let me tell
you how it's done let's say this minds
gonna catch you do this except he can't
be contained okay there's this yeah I
was telling Jackson earlier about this
this story called where he gets arrested
intentionally to go to a supermax prison
so that he can start a riot get everyone
all riled up and confused and then in
the energy what you do go find the crime
boss is responsible for his family's
death
[Music]
Wow it's time to do some disciplinarian
England its interrogated how should we
interrogate it
let me go you son of a [ __ ] okay we
know what the name of the bad guys teach
I think you lose points for every guy
who successfully gives you information
and then you kill him anyway hey you're
the Punisher for what yeah life I'm just
the angriest trench coat man this game
looks really good for ps2 graphics it
does yeah like if you told me this was
like early they're not only burning
who's gonna voice Church now
[Music]
all right I always love when people try
to go the punisher into into fighting
when he's had a hit like a known career
for killing like like 50,000 people no I
think I'm gonna interrogate him some
questions okay alright yeah we did we
lose 250 points because this game was
getting a lot of in a lot of trouble
because it was like glorifying just like
ultra violence and killing everybody so
they're like okay we have to put in some
stuff where it seems like the player
will get in trouble for being are you so
when you kill everybody you have like a
hard time getting points hold on there's
there's a Crouch button there okay all
right Maria
[Music]
break junior ps2 yeah it looks it looks
great for its age hey how's it going
Anton Anton's animations what's up what
was I doing
Oh oh my god this is like the best
course of the story this is kind of gone
I already love this plot twist
how much ammo do we have we have six
bullets for shells
I'm sorry shell the gunplay feels so
satisfying like it's just so fun now you
just got just picking up weapons okay I
mean it's not like there's any like
shortage of them you would be hey Sher
Shah Adnan I hope I said your name even
within the realm of being correct
awesome how about the new heck man movie
coming out Oh with with the guy from odd
occurrences where he plays the sheriff
hi Joey
food win of course who would win a
crying over their wives mad spawn or
Punisher Oh
[Music]
I I'd want to check that out too I think
that would be a worthy battle you can
also have throwing like dum-dum we've
got to find your wife oh no I don't know
you suit yourself
ha ha no I'm not that kid that came very
close to hitting her you I think you
lose points for killing civilians my
Asian would underscore dude Mendoza
kill them all something about don't
letting the scum die I don't know mr.
freeze can also cry about his life
there's so many guys really sad about
use like run out of reasons for
someone's become something just occurred
to me I gotta put on subtitles
oh yeah that's important
I'm gonna put the brightness up a little
also so it comes across better on stream
yes except changes game settings gore
level I wanted to see if there's a
higher level but there was it was off
and that's not right uh alright that
seems about right yes there we go
subtitles and also brighter so people
can see the ultraviolet
why does it suddenly seem louder it
could be some kind of glitch there we go
all right back to disciplining just I
even let him finish his sentence I feel
bad you ever just walk into a crack
house and then just kill a bajillion
people are you a criminal men just
people addicted to crack and they're in
listen I got points so I assumed he was
alright I'm gonna go back to the shotgun
thoughts on the Netflix show so far well
I've only got about I don't want to tell
people how many episodes I've been seen
or enjoyed it
hands up don't shoot
oh yeah the subtitles appears like
caption boxes it's great
who else wants to be taught a lesson for
I am the lesson teaching her Xavier I
have a question if Deadpool hates the
rest of the world for outcasting him
does that mean he hates the writers for
making people outcasts him well yeah
that's why Deadpool at one point goes
nuts he tries to murder all the right
O's hey I saved you that was all I
killed those three guys before they
could murder eyes him yeah okay all
right continue about your business
Thanks like he's yeah nicely recognized
yeah like what was he doing on the
street later what's your opinion of
Punisher max oh it's a [ __ ] vest it's
one of my favorite comic arcs ever in
the history of the universe it's so good
hey I'm gonna ask you some questions
over in here buy this and do this yeah
hold on I want to interrogate him first
[Music]
little does he know thanks Diego Rivera
here's the bestest man I'm gonna throw
this guy out a window just for you
that's for you buddy it's your tribute I
hope the sledgehammer likes his new home
oh hell yeah
holy [ __ ] this is excessive III don't
even know how he can handle it he's got
some really really strong forearms you
know those little things that you shoot
do you uh oh dude
how'd you kill him I pushed him down and
then just shot him I went I meant to
grab him to interrogate him hold on
there's by somebody in here all right
hold on you're coming back here with me
I saw a window with your name on it
what's your opinion on Ragnarok I
haven't been able to see it yet sadly
but I'd very much liked it special
interrogation tell me information but
you get minus 104 you get minus 100
points but you get so much satisfaction
from it you know
oh boy YouTube's not gonna like this one
there's only one there's only one way a
man can gain that much forearm strength
yeah you know that little uh that that
thing that you little metal thing that
you squeeze that I was like a spring in
it Punisher is just using one of those
for like 15 hours every day or it's just
shake weights
yeah no problem buddy what are you doing
in this crack house thanks for wasting
him all right so you're I appreciate it
summer so cool everyone loves the
Punisher just the nicest guy I'm seeing
like big guys in church maybe we should
no man you're good
I'm just here just um with your
bulletproof TV doing drugs is a crime -
yeah but it's not like a murder E crime
fair you see a lot of people get
Punisher confused with uh with Judge
Dredd and think that he just shoots
jaywalkers no you got to be like a real
douchebag real right god I got a really
good man that's basically the like all
issues of Judge Dredd there there was
one issue uh where like a girl who is in
love with him who was like an
established character finally announced
her feelings do you yeah and then kissed
him and he goes unlawful contact with a
judge for months in the ISO cubes she
goes up in Judge Dredd there's this
prison that's just a median on a highway
like it's just this little island it's
like a just like a like 15 feet of grass
and trees and you you just get set down
there and you're you're allowed to go
free if you can make it across the
highway and the cars are going
constantly at like 200 miles an hour so
not many so no one has been able to do
it should I should I really you know
what
they didn't ask if they should with my
family you didn't show Frankie jr. Eddie
any kind of remorse oh Jesus pretty good
I feel bad now oh it was a bit much yeah
[ __ ] nailed it wasn't that cool dude
oh you're a criminal too so criminal
took another criminal hostage I'm gonna
interrogate you since you haven't had a
bad enough day yet you know you tell me
what I wanna know leagues
oh really that's it all righty then well
uh speaking of window tossing huh I want
to try well I just bonked him on the
head we got points for that one yeah
yeah I feel I wanted to throw I don't
know how to throw them uh punish her ass
to where the trigger his words look
further okay no human is innocent yeah I
bet that guy pirated DVDs oh I'm so
sorry I grazed your shoulder sir how is
my bathroom
the judge dredd would arrest my ass she
has only one way to read that many of
them you know there's a lot of them you
can't buy them all it's insane
no human could afford that I appreciate
the art then they're always like really
old ones I buy the new ones but the old
ones um when it's like from like 1982
and the author is dead probably just
look it up no no bars right job you just
heard all the simultaneous like screams
up oh my god
I'm gonna save them both and watch it's
gonna be so cool I did it I saved them
both what do you yeah I didn't almost do
that all right yeah wait what's in here
Oh some drug guys oh yeah no problem
have fun being in the closet or whatever
Oh No
have a gun pointed at this guy and he's
like I don't have any recollection of
being at this crack house also I've
chosen to live as a gay man I have some
questions for you sir
that's when you put a gun in his face oh
oh thank you how do I throw him well
that works yeah good enough yeah
I'm gonna get so killed doing what I'm
doing I need to go find cover holy [ __ ]
that was cool
oh I feel bad I actually shot that guy
in the nard
you know I don't wanna I don't want to
do that how do I it's gotta be oh yes
yeah yeah disciplinarian ting Jim Carrey
is also kind of down done with movies
for the most part but why are we talking
about Jim Carrey Jim Carrey played The
Punisher in 2003 I'm not afraid of you
and then you just walk over and he quits
no no no I'm gonna special interrogate
you I have that logo tattooed on my arm
now I'm pretty damaged his forearms are
so powerful oh geez
time to call it a night whoops well
didn't get any information out of him
you know just um but I still feel proud
of what I did you feel better I feel
better I had a great time this is this
is like a really nice night for Punisher
like this is like for some people this
is like watching a good TV show yeah
yeah you know just sit down afterward a
killing yes massacring dozens of people
oh look look check this out look at the
license plate
a SM 129 or yeah a SM 129 that's the
first appearance of the Punisher is
amazing special do you think I would get
away with being a 5-10 Punisher hey man
that's about how tall Wolverine is
accuracy 37% Wolverine ass
Wolverines a short man yes to be like
five seven or something I'm taller than
Tom Cruise yeah Tom Cruise is also very
short see his last movie was true crimes
in 2016
true crimes true crimes was that like a
sequel to True Lies all right who was
co-hosting with Xavier this is my buddy
Jackson him and I have been friends
since fifth grade he's in a lot of my
old my old let's plays yes
um mr. waffle says davier can you help
me with voice acting like do you want me
to do a voice acting thing for you or do
you want me to give you tips because I'm
not exactly a professional Xavier did
you know Sony is gonna make a silver
sable on blackhat team up movie and a
morbius movie and also a Green Goblin
one I didn't hear about the Green Goblin
one how tall are you Xavier uh [ __ ] I
don't know I think like five ten now
five nine maybe yes everyone saying I
don't put more effort into the game than
Rocksteady did with Arkham Knight this
is very true let's go look at our armory
good lord
all right oh we get a flamethrower oh
yeah this is all the guns you get so you
have to like find them in missions to
unlock them here okay but I think later
you can just start spawning in certain
levels
with the guns so you've already unlocked
yeah yeah Jackson's he's a swell guy
he's been in a couple of my videos
before I've even I even made a joke
directly at him in my splatterhouse
review where I said that one's for you
Jackson after showing revolver ocelot oh
yeah yeah upgrades
what should we upgrade we haven't we
didn't have much problem with taking
damage yet so I wouldn't bother I don't
want to attach a silencer I don't want a
silencer cuz can I turn it off if I
wanted to attach grenade launcher do we
have enough I'll increase gear grenade
capacity cuz I don't even think I a
grenades um
someone says their mom asked what his
hobby is and he just responds guns what
are you Frank Castle best spider-man
movie and why jeez I get asked this like
eight times a day it's it's to the best
spider-man movie is obviously spider-man
3 and anyone who has any problem at all
with how how will that movie handled any
of its its plot is just wrong they're
wrong yeah Xavier what's the weirdest
thing Punisher has done okay so one time
in the 80s jigsaw decided to get like
plastic surgery to look like Frank
Castle and and framed him right so Frank
Castle had to lie low for a while by
looking like someone else so he met with
a prostitute who is an ex-player
and then he had her help him help him
out with some plastic surgery so so she
cut his hair and like permed it up a
little and you know changed around a
little bit of his facial structure and
then did some some modifications on his
skin so when he woke up from the surgery
he was a black guy and Punisher was a
black guy for like a whole week and he
was still like drowsy from the the drugs
from the surgery so he gets in his car
and starts driving down the highway
and he's like kind of like driving a
little badly and then he gets pulled
over by a cop and then like nine other
cops roll up like you on drugs son and
he goes no I'm just and then they just
start kicking his ass like he was a
black guy for fifteen minutes he got
pulled over by a cop and then gets beat
up by like nine of them at once and then
him and Luke Cage team up and then they
fight the racist cops together and then
and then Punishers plastic surgery
starts wearing off and then this is us
their skin starts returning to its
original color and the story cut a
storyline for that was called fade to
white I mean that's not quite as weird
as the Geisha Punisher oh yeah there's
this alternate okay there's the Marvel
mangaverse which is like the manga
Marvel Universe and in that the Punisher
is a female geisha who tickles crime
bosses to death with a whip and I asked
Peter David about it I was like what the
hell was going on with that and I asked
him at Comic Con and I even made a video
about it so if you go back and watch my
comic-con video I think Jackson is doing
that yeah he filmed it and he was also
in it for a little bit you could go see
my interview with Peter David where I
asked him a bunch of weird questions
Xavier arrow or flash uh which one's
useful arrow obviously arrow yeah you
could you could totally take on his
boxing glove arrows if you see what they
can do he it's maybe if he started using
tactical nuke arrows okay well war zone
okay wait hold on one there's something
that you got checked between missions um
is it the war Journal
[Music]
news clippings every mission gives you a
news clipping you you ready vigilante
murder spree kills dozens of homeless
yeah like I said do we know if they're
even criminals yes a criminal chart look
at all these crimes we have to stop the
ventriloquist we kill him
I'd probably which is your favorite
series Gotham or Smallville oh jeez it's
like asking someone if they prefer
getting stabbed or getting shot more
it's like you could survive more stab
wounds I know a lot of people though are
really really affectionate or small
drilled Oh apparently it kind of like
picked himself up after a while
but I watched a couple episodes I was
just not impressed
um but uh yeah I'm confused is arrow the
same guy as Green Arrow yes mm-hmm yes I
love how excited Xavier gets when
talking about comics well yeah man it's
like my favorite thing in the universe
I got a Punisher tattoo yesterday yeah
it's a four of the different skull logos
because he has so many and they were
around my arm and like a band now uh
Xavier where are you gonna when are you
gonna play spongebob battle for bikini
bottom that game is quality that's the
one where they they do all the racing
right and plankton turns into a kaiju
yes I have that game wait did I give it
back to Game Stop in like 2011
I don't know I think I mean how hard can
that be to get alright let's hold on
what's theirs punishment mode let's go
let's go stop this chop shop like that
scene punished in daredevil season 2
yeah look crossover would you want to
see with the Punisher Xavier want to see
Moon Knight and Punisher hang out more
often they only kind of do but a tragedy
of epic proportions most would say so
both these characters are from the
comics and both of them go on different
very different things some people just
have no seats up here who would she
become yeah that's his last name
he just gets like crapped on by life
constantly he has the hardest time ever
doing anything yeah and because he gets
promoted to like Commissioner for like a
week and then gets like demoted and then
yeah right and then he gets put on the
Punisher task force which is basically
like a joke part of the police yeah it's
it's one guy in an office yeah The
Punisher task force is supposed to be
looking for him it's two guys and one of
them kills himself because his careers
falling so hard so it feels really bad
about it but um Richtofen she goes to LA
and then tries to like she keeps
flirting with this girl no no no yeah
she she has this girlfriend and she's
like I'm sorry but I I just want to be
with be with my boyfriend again you know
in she's like you're taking already and
then she hunts down that guy's boyfriend
and then because she's a cop she pulls
him over and goes so hey it looks like
yeah a tail light out there he goes no I
don't and then she goes and you wax it
with a baton and he goes Oh
yeah and then she breaks that guy's nose
but then soap after a lot of misfortune
which I'll talk about throughout the
screen because there's a lot of
hilarious bad things that happen to him
eventually just like quits being a
police officer joins me and then he goes
to the coliform store and it shows the
cover it says they always bend over for
the soap it was like the very final
issue is like this character because he
was about to kill himself before
Punisher was like that's for losers and
now it's cuts to like later on or it's
like Punisher is doing that here's what
happened everybody things he goes a soap
found a previously unknown Asst skill
right yeah and then move to Hollywood
and started a new career and so I'm so
confused right now what are over
stopping the shop top oh my god I want
this baseball bat how do I grab it no
not a 9-point like that
I want this oh I'm so happy I'm gonna go
I'm gonna I'm gonna have a great time
with this
yeah Chili's a1c withdraw I don't know
I'm so glad I have this stupid Max Payne
dodge we need to interrogate him we need
to interrogate the guys for the skulls
over their heads how do I use the
baseball bat do I just throw it that's
all I'm gonna tear agait to super hard
where's the cool spot to interrogate it
it doesn't seem there's any special
interrogation spots in here
there will be soon all right I'll take
you over here this seems like a good
spot
Oh what should we do who's in charge
okay Carlo I like that section in Max
Payne where you have nothing but a
baseball bat you know ponit Max Payne is
basically the first Punisher game Hey
look I'm just a big wrench yeah bet we
could do some damage with this or we're
just gonna throw it at them again or
just throw it at their general vicinity
yeah I don't know how to hit someone
with things but I sure can hit people at
a distance where are the other drugs
going
yeah these guys aren't mechanics they're
chop shotguns they stole these cars from
hardworking and Americans oh god I
didn't mean to shoot him in the way I
thought I did
I shot him in the crotch I feel really
bad that was horrible I'm this is a
really powerful shotgun yeah that took a
lot of tries oh oh dude oh dude is there
anybody else in the room Hey
oh yeah like anyone else no one
interrupts my special interrogation oh
yeah
[Music]
yeah I'll let you go so yeah there's a
patch on the PC version of this game
that takes out the censored versions of
these because it zooms in and like puts
on a filter oh yeah it's [ __ ] there's a
version of that where just shows
everything punished here versus John
wick versus Max Payne oh I want that
movie hello sir
Oh your man yeah we make people's eyes
bat I wish there was a shovel that'll be
great he imagined we could do with a
shovel they'd be like Jack from receival
seven high just throw hey everyone I'm
cosplaying as Batman on the ground
oh are you did that really kill him
though or did it just for errantly yeah
but like open the door though he's gonna
kill me I'll open the door and think
that I'm not the Punisher it's the
perfect plan
ah the framerate
I hit that guy so hard that it made the
frame frame right tank oh I'm so bad in
this area wow that guy through a
computer at me he's that character from
holy [ __ ]
he's that character from gmod idiot box
he through a computer at me and I
responded in kind a bottle I don't know
I want to go find out do I play si MP
what's that plenty of targets plenty of
bullets
I got such a such a deadpan delivery san
andreas Oh
I even know that was a thing well it ate
some odd hey check it out check it out
oh my god
that was that was different than what I
thought it would be oh they got John
Rick's bar
oh yeah this is in the John wick in a
row tickets these guys are having a
rough time yeah that's my favorite hey
hey come back I have a question to ask
you I didn't either
oh my god friendly fire is a thing
that's the best
I forgot how to throw a grenade actually
I don't think I ever at any point knew
how to throw grenades what's the button
oh okay something else is going on here
okay um let's throw a flashbang no down
oh my god we've entered rage mode though
okay in which we run around and do rage
we got it we got to charge that up again
okay there's a lot of John Wick's cars
in here yeah there are um I feel like
John Wick's gonna be really mad yeah
he's gonna be especially pissed this
time around if I know this is gonna be
no one to kill so just could be angry
can you imagine of one of those revenge
movies like like in the style of John
Luke but he gets there and someone else
already killed all the guys don't like
his is kick-ass like getting ready to
fight everyone montage was completely
useless like a grenade launcher in hand
he's got sunglasses on he kicks in the
door he's like full Rambo mode he looks
around and there's just guts hanging
from the ceiling and like limbs
everywhere he goes oh I was gonna do
that what do I think of that the Batman
court of owls comics they're pre they're
pretty awesome um I really like the
Scott Snyder when I'm not on Batman
this is the best I'm so glad they give
you know where I got this game where the
receptionist at my college yeah yeah
somewhat
oh no oh good kill him I want to
interrogate this other guy wait no no no
no no I ate the wrong button
[ __ ] all right can I reload the
checkpoint restart section yeah okay
yeah holy crap haha one place is selling
this game for $198 $198 Jesus don't see
then there's there's some more decent
ones what's your cringy for Sona Xavier
oh um I don't have one but I know that
give you a Fox know if you look up your
name plus the hedgehog you'll find some
[ __ ] on Google look up Jackson the
Hedgehog
I think I went to a completely different
area than last time
wait here we go now a bath really we
seem to get that guy an interrogator
well yeah a newsie he's easy but there's
newsy what huh
Brad now I got you oh I feel bad already
make us whole again ah [ __ ] now what I'm
gonna get this right hey Godzilla
Mendoza I got to meet Wilfredo Batman
Beyond yesterday and found out some
things about this show like Batman
Beyond was going to be really
kid-friendly like ultimate spider-man oh
I'm so glad they didn't go home yeah
it's so much it's so much better um
Batman Beyond is hilarious in the fact
that Terry McGinnis kills people all the
time and Bruce never has anything to say
about it like he like he's doing fraid
of him remember the terrific trio those
like fantastic for parody guys
Terry actively murdered all of them like
he turned on a ventilation shaft that
sucked in two of them dissipated the
atoms of one of them and then like like
like brian ground up the other one in
like a fan blade and then the third guy
he just beat to death like he punched
him and totally stopped moving
yeah
ah
it's very delicate procedure tell me
what I need to know
damnit this is really hard no wait haha
alright I give up make us whole again
screws go tight all around call ins in
the dark machine step 3 exceptin 100
yeah
stick a needle in your eye accept it and
then uh convergence I kicked in the door
to a room where I already killed
everyone and now I feel like a goofball
okay how do I throw the grenades
exámenes watch some funny show I've
watched some of it and I'm quite
enjoying the or I very much enjoyed the
amount that I want oh my god that guy's
last words were please let me go and
then I just didn't quite hear him in
time and then shot him new she's new in
this place you changed your mind if you
did here I want to consider it for like
a bill a second the answer would have
been no oh yeah there's this leather
trench coat is pretty badass
oh dude this one's bad okay so this is a
Cromer which they use
tell me x-men evolution is awesome yeah
oh oh look at his head so shiny man he
looks like Norrin Radd like that's an
open casket that need someone to see how
it shiny here that is I give an open
casket for a guy who who went through
that cuz everyone would be like damn you
went out in a really cool way oh god the
knife just smack him so hard he dies let
him out I have a cat who's very very
angry about being in the room for too
long
how's the headphone splitter working
they're working good it's right that's
so weird because I all
III have these same headphone splitters
and whenever I tried to stream with Josh
they would never work so we were both
you like getting maybe half the audio
don't kill me I have to discipline all
these oh my God all these Crimmins ah
Jesus he did it again he thought it was
so cool he did it again
how do I throw the grenade someone
please please help that just shoots the
other gun when you're dual wielding
d-pad just switches the guns okay this
Crouch is this flops this belly flops
this Crouch is also where are the other
drugs going triangle oh my god
holy [ __ ] oh god this is super cool oh
man that was great
activate activate to me whatever a dull
moment when you're the Punisher
oh the crotch
oh my god I jumped behind him and then
broke his neck that was super cool shoot
back and I cut there's just a guy like
holding the hands up like I give up hey
what's up I'm using you as a human
shield
alright which button is it yeah I just
got a make sure you got to be really
thorough or else you'll get people like
jigsaw coming back constantly you know
you think you killed him by shoving him
into a vortex of swirling broken glass
at a recycling plant turns out he's just
gonna come back tougher than before
because he scarred up now cuz everyone
knows when you have scars it makes you
physically stronger yeah what do you
think of Punishers favorite dishes
revenge
serve a dish best served cold
Oh blind lawyer man who may or may not
have a cameo on this game
man right on there may or may not be a
lot of Marvel characters in this game
surprisingly I want you to guess the
most outlandish Marvel characters that
could probably show up in this game like
who would just be like really like kind
of weird not a place spider-man is off
the table
he does not show up Oh Turk yeah Turk
Turk is the best even all the Netflix
shows but Turk is what's his power you
still man yes don't man don't man it's
tilt man shows up I want stilt man to
show up Oh No
I'm in the girls bathroom
stop being a criminal Minh
I saved you after traumatizing it's
pretty high charging Mike Mike
traumatization count is higher than my
kill count I trauma ties everyone who
doesn't die
[Music]
Oh oh my god is an adamantium knife
never seen oh that was so great um so
some people are guessing daredevil some
are guessing fantastic for some someone
said Ironman daredevil and Stevie Wonder
the ventriloquist oh okay all right cool
tell me about you oh geez tell me where
the other drugs he collects the money
gives me my take okay that's cool all
right bye oh god oh no Derek Darth pool
asks if I can play a carnage in the
venom movie movie yeah there's a venom
movie coming out in October next year
the Tom Hardy is venom that's right yeah
someone says I'm thinking of doing
Punisher cosplay all I need is some
Kevlar white spray paint a trench coat
and a haircut that's what we all need I
say spider-man 2099 only in a row
because there's a death battle between
them swear to me there's a lotta there's
a lot of pretty cool is there a stair
kick okay there we go what is this
strange contraption it's like some kind
of vertical staircase I don't understand
yeah Tommy you see anything I'm having
way too much fun like I feel like a bad
person because I'm enjoying this game so
much it gets rid of your points that
you're enjoying the murder too much they
don't want to encourage punisher
impersonators oh that's a cool thing in
the comic sirs hey flashbang i did it
was the fun l1o which is I guess the
secondary fire if you don't have a dual
world
oh you that's I want to ask you a
question
and the question is murder I just hit
him hold on got it really gotta be
thorough okay
yeah I gotta really get in there good
why is it sir I do not want you to have
had a quadruple tap that's how you to
stop the zombie virus oh my god some
people don't even ever get to see him
coming he just gets up behind him and
that's it can I use this forklift to
kill anybody with I feel like it would
be a really big missed opportunity if I
couldn't I really want to cook lift
murder someone oh I'm having way too
much fun man can you imagine if Punisher
just had like a Punisher mobile that was
just a forklift
that's like three shots to the neck yeah
I apologize for not doing better sir
because that probably hurt more I try to
be at least a you know a kosher murder
man not tortured except when I do
torture people you know but like I don't
want him to suffer except when I do yeah
go see if the Punisher is hiding in that
train car just fire a warning shot at
the ground scatter the roaches
[Applause]
[Music]
I feel like it's really bad when they're
like crying like that they gotta be
discipline no matter what oh this is the
new chief family okay so the the the new
cheese there's a manu cheese who's like
the crime boss like she's she's some old
lady and in the comics Punisher fights
tries to chase her down and assassinate
her at the zoo right and they throws her
into the polar bear pit and she gets
attacked by polar bears and by the end
of it she has no arms or legs left and
her scalp has been like partially
removed so she's wearing a wig and she's
just this like quadriplegic sitting in a
wheelchair going how do you think I feel
when one of the other criminals goes hey
MA hey how you feeling
and and you're like she Punisher keeps
having a hard time killing her because
she's just so determined and it gets to
the point where she's like at on the
ground gnawing at his ankles so he grabs
her picks her up and then just Chuck's
her into a burning building finally
ended boy am I gonna have a hell of a
time convincing my parents to let me buy
this hey ex how long do you think you'll
be screaming for I was thinking about
two hours yeah 10 minutes yeah we're
about halfway through it maybe night now
maybe three hours if we're having a lot
of fun and also if I want to hand out
the controller to Jackson which I'm
thinking about doing just cuz that would
be funny I've only started playing it
yesterday yeah I you know actually
yesterday was my day off but I still
ended up driving an hour all the way to
the school to go pick up a copy of this
from the receptionist just cuz I cuz he
told me like hardcore you have to bring
it back by the 28th so I'm gonna try and
like get everything I can for a review
ready before then so you know there's
gonna be a lot of playing this over over
the break let's go let's go look at the
newspaper clippings from now on yes yeah
let's see we got
she kills innocent mechanics oh my god
did you guess it right auto mechanic
well there's just like it looks like
every single piece of news has something
to do with the Punisher there's a skull
there's a picture of his face
yeah do I think spider-man 2099 could be
Batman Beyond that's actually a pretty
tough matchup um not on the basis of
Terry McGinnis being as much of like a
tactical genius as Batman but more so
just because he's just so much meaner
cuz he actually murders people and he
just is constantly beating people to
death well like there was that one thing
where he kicked that guy into that
control panel so that his like taser
knuckles like caught it and it
electrocuted him and like Terry could
have probably gone over and helped him
and was like no I got killed my dad by
the new chief is on my list now my son
Bobby he's his Lucky's bars in office
running prostitution and drugs from
there it's a wiseguy bar nobody decent
hangs out there tonight I'm shutting
Bobby down objectives kill Bobby Nucci
all right that's pretty straight for if
Jake Paul was cast in a Marvel movie who
would he play Johnny Storm really take
in how perfect the thing I just said was
yeah
my favorite bar and yet
Punisher has a super gravelly voice not
quite as bad as a Christian Bale Batman
but what cuz it's not it's not like an
artificial gravel where he's just going
like he just actually sounds like that
if only you'd come to me earlier Tony
maybe I could have helped you that's so
kiss hope is an informant for blemishes
or not like because the The Punisher
Task Force is so much of a joke that he
actively just helps him yeah cuz he has
no chance of catching him that's up for
you oh he's so one time there because
there's a lot of like just like side
stuff about him and then in the series
one time soap goes to a bar just to meet
just like to just chill cuz he's really
depressed about losing his job as like
police commissioner and he meets an
older lady there are hundreds and now
they have like us they they actually
came from the same town cuz he talks
about how he was like put up for
adoption in like 19 like like 80 84 or
something or whatever by the time that
game came out heard that that comic and
she's like yeah you know I actually had
a son that I put up for adoption
around that time too in that same town I
think even that same orphanage and you
know he's like you know you would have
been the same age as my mom man that's
crazy to think me and your son would
have been in the same nursery and then
he ends up taking that girl home so the
words you dumbass lush was a comic book
character that is so ironic considering
what happens later in this game anyway
hey
place hey you doing man yeah no one
expects the Punisher Inquisition I'll
kill all of you without even picking up
a gun I have so much Kevlar you can't
stop me and bad gaming coming out from
behind wins the race holy [ __ ] you
should review spider-man 2 for the GBA
using an emulator of course you know I
could probably figure out a way to do
that I mean I have a way to record piece
of footage now it's just I don't know
I've been kind of worried about doing
more spider-man reviews since I don't
want to necessarily be only a spider-man
channel but thank you so much for the
donation why is this guy Pistons who's
your boss fight Oh
hang on let me reload wrong Bobby Nucci
he actually has one of those stark tech
invisible helmets oh here you go Jackson
you're playing now alright
punish them discipline the
disciplinarian I'll figure it out as I
go it's become a spider-man in elsa
channel i have both costumes at the
ready good shot how's the 2003 hulk game
review doing it's going fantastic i
actually just got a whole lot of
progress editing it the other day it's
just been a busy weekend and i'm gonna
pick it up later after how much were
those tattoos which ones like just all
of them were the ones that i got
yesterday because the ones i got
yesterday it was basically my christmas
present like my mom used her christmas
bonus to just pay for him you know just
because it's like what do you get a 19
year old for christmas so I was like
yeah it's getting our tattoo and we
actually got a deal because the the
tattoo artist is a good friend of my
name good friend of mine whoops whoops
okay bye Anton's animations Gina Hardy
you're not too late we've only been
going for an hour we might go for
another hour or two
look at those arcade machines man what
are those can you throw someone into
that all man can you grab some pliers
jam into a guy's temple and then throw
him into that pinball machine it's one
of the steps
yeah there you go are you just getting
around the corner so he can't hit you
and then just pouring automatic gunfire
into his face that's so good
I like how how they didn't want you to
run over and just stab him to death so
they had him behind a couch yeah like
this is such a lame boss fight you're
just standing in a doorway just shooting
one guy I should do a retrospective on
spider-man games you know that's not a
bad idea I should try that out but um
anyway the tattoos all all of the ones
on my arm that I got yesterday ended up
running us about 120 so that was my that
was my early Christmas present
yeah
Xavier what's better Gore or sex in your
games
I prefer door because I feel like video
game sex is never gonna look good and
it's always gonna just appear as
polygons just clipping into each other
so much I'll be now for Mom all right
Manu Qi all right we're gonna have to go
find that that go to a zoo coz there's
also a scene where we're because the
polar bears aren't immediately crazy
Punisher has to get him riled up so he
goes over and punches one in the face
and there's a panel of punished you're
just punching a polar bear how can he
take a luzia pistol and a shotgun to the
face he just has so much crime oh man
look all right all right let's go back
to our apartment and check out our light
you do this part okay so what we need to
do I'm hyped for that spider-man
retrospective yeah like playing through
all the spider-man games and reviewing
I'm one by one that would be fun
we should definitely try that just join
what's up hey Nightwing 22 make sure to
a everyone make sure we can get as many
people on here as possible for the next
hour or two that we're gonna finish this
up go tweet this like crazy tag me in it
and I'll just retweet a little bunch
I'll pull out my phone and do that while
Jax is it massacring bad guys yeah let's
check out some news clippings all right
let's
mafia safehouse destroyed by Punisher
I'm surprised didn't just say local bar
just local bar run by a mom-and-pop who
are really nice are the headphones
letters doing that thing again I can
only hear out of one side well now I
can't hear any of it hang on we're gonna
figure this out stupid headphones who
would win Charles Stiles vs. Frank
Castle Charles Stiles mystery diners
yeah he has mystery diners let's get
some upgrades what should we do just so
he can be even more overpowered let's
get body armor we just can't you already
can hardly die longer slaughter mode
alright there you go now you can stab
dudes for longer
did you see the trailer for rampage oh
yeah it's a movie but we're uh it's
basically King Kong mixed with the first
blender just radio James Franco aim
Johnson and King Kong isn't it basically
okay I mean it's not supposed to be King
Kong but it's based on a video game
based on King Kong and Godzilla like
rampage is supposed to be like a parody
of like like kaiju movies like that okay
um so yeah it's basically just King Kong
okay except changes yes Savior you seen
Justice League not yet um hello
Unitas gaming Oh de name yacht so many
good levels in this game yeah man okay
so uh Dane is actually the guy who
donated $100 on the patreon which had
the reward for that is you get to just
pick what I review yeah so because he
did that I managed to go find a copy of
this game and I'm working on that review
just for him
yeah all right war zone central oh my
god we are going to a zoo oh my god I'm
so excited
forget it girl is avenge for Bobby's
death so she had Bushwhacker kidnap her
Joan I followed them to the Central Zoo
it's a trap but I can't let them kill
Joan it's a trap but I can't let them
okay so his neighbor Joan in the comic
is really really fun because she is the
most mousy like they call her Joan the
mouse because she is just so quiet and
so like patient and so nice she's just
like really nervous
hello mr. castle how are you I noticed
you got a lot of blood on you there it's
it's a hope no no that's yours I'm gonna
go back to my apartment now if you'd
like to come over for a sandwich I can
make you one all right goodbye mr.
castle like she's the cutest character
Yeah right because she's just so
innocent and punisher convinces her to
leave New York because it's it's a
shitty place and he's like yeah go out
and kids she's always wanted a house out
on the country yeah like a farm with
bunnies and he says you go you go out
there and do it all you got to do is
just go right yeah and then later on in
another story like something like 30
issues later he spills on to the flight
lawn at her house out in the out in the
country it's covered in like his own
blood in bullet holes and he's like like
laying face down in her pond she goes
over and goes hi Frank
he goes hey Joe so then she has to nurse
him back to health
oh and then he has to uh his like he
knows the criminals that shot him up
we're coming for them yeah so he has her
like by herself like like home alone in
the house like fill it full of traps and
like nail bombs and like c4 and [ __ ]
uh-huh and then he just sits in his bed
because he's like he can't stand up
because his ribs hurt too much yeah so
he just has his bed pulled over to the
to the window and he just sits there
with an m60 just shooting out while
sitting down and then when he's done he
just lays back down
pretty good Jones the best
okay let's start mission yeah you got to
read these comics it's dude any like all
the Garth Ennis Punishers are amazing
the the welcome back Frank Marvel
Knights Punisher and then the 2001
series Bushwhacker looks like uh who
does he look like to you he looks like
Duke Nukem but he has a gun for an arm
that's his power
this is his unique ability my unique
ability is I have a gun for an arm
there's a lot of bad 3 2001 asure
felonies in place
[Music]
yeah Garth Ennis wrote the script for
this game C month I think there's
another thing it was Jimmy Paul me ah T
I think was the other writer do you
intend to review Marvel Ultimate
Alliance - sorry to ask again if I
missed a question keep in mind I'm just
trying to like I just want yeah I just
want to do this I was gonna hand the
controller back to you but I just it
needs to happen you know all of x-men
evolution is on YouTube no I didn't know
that that's actually awesome because I
love that show and more people than to
watch it it's really I think the best
x-men cartoon you freakin psycho oh God
you should also review Batman Begins for
the ps2 you know I actually know where
to get a copy of that and I've been
thinking about trying to get that lately
well anyway he gave us the information
but uh you can't not do it
you can't not I don't care about the
point oh my god rockso oh my god how do
I feel about the 20 2004 Punisher movie
I got into a very heated argument
yesterday with someone as I said I
didn't like it is because I think
Punisher in that movie doesn't do enough
punishing things alright he spends most
of his time doing silly [ __ ] like like I
want to remind you that this is a movie
where he tries to convince the crime
boss that his wife is cheating on him
with his gay best friend so he takes her
car drives it to the crime bosses best
friend's house puts down a fake fire
hydrant so that she gets tickets cost
room on his car even though she's not
aware that it's gone drives it back to
their place without anyone knowing just
so it creates a fake alibi
and then like there's so many silly
absurdist things that he does to make
this like hey I oh I forgot to give you
the controller back and he does all
these crazy stupid things to make the
crime boss kill his wife and best friend
and then he shows up at the very end
just to go ha ha I made you kill your
friend for no reason and then that's
like this that's not something Punisher
would do a lot of people complain about
the scene rate tortures the guy with a
popsicle and makes him think it's uh
it's a blowtorch
that was actually straight out of the
comics that's something Punisher would
do by the way if you're not dual
wielding something you can hit l1 to
throw that grenade but I guess you're
dual wielding m16 yes fun fact Punisher
hates the m16 because uh in Vietnam it
was like like really prone to like
falling apart and jamming and [ __ ] I
think yeah there's like a whole issue of
Punisher Mad Max whereas like he's
really calm and a nice issue for hey by
the way when you go up to someone hit X
to grab them okay take him over to that
thing oh god it's okay at least yeah if
this guy gets killed you can use higher
then oh wait special interrogate that
guy instead quick kill this this schmuck
alright let's let's go take him back to
that fountain and let's turn it into a
blood fountain alright well we'll see
we'll see if I can okay okay so you push
it up on the stick to make it go you
have to keep it in that bar so push up
on the left one
pull back though you got to pull it back
first and then push forward oh yeah and
then ah you're gonna kill him hold it
and push it up on a little of it a
little bit
okay here you go yeah keep it in that
spot there we go
just pull back really hard then push
forward hold on look at the fountain
what's my favorite superhero movie um I
like a lot of them uh I really love Iron
Man one
I think that's even though I I have some
problems with Iron Man as a character
later on in the MCU that is just such an
awesome movie but anyway yeah the
problem with the 2004 Punisher movie is
there's like only really a very small
handful of instances of him in the
Punisher skull t-shirt running around
fighting dudes with a gun like what the
plunger alright Oh
- can you Tara gate him by giving him a
swirly
[Applause]
[Music]
you gotta put hold on push up on it and
just like like maybe see if it goes
right push down out okay there you go
right now push there you go okay push up
just to keep it in their zone okay we
got five points now just push you do
think yeah
Punisher is every stir is his straight
up every bully in high school yeah man
oh god this is uncomfortable yeah cuz
that toilet was really gross to like did
you see how Brown it was in there oh
yeah what it yeah judging by his
reaction Xavier is gonna have a lot of
good things to say about it dude what is
there a complain about this game's
fantastic you should review Ironman ps2
pc version as it's the best Ironman game
in my opinion and way better than the
360 ps3 crash what I've been hearing
I played the ps3 version of that Ironman
game and it was so bad that I never
finished it and I returned it do I like
the Netflix Punisher series boy do I
have a breeze you know that spider-man 2
novelization when MJ was running back
Peter was said that the guy that was
looking back at MJ was Frank Castle I've
heard about that we're there hold on
don't shoot a hostage
no that's not good okay I made it dammit
I made you okay you click on the stick
to zoom in real close for fine a mode
there you know you got a cam in the face
a lot of people talked about this this
random guy in a black t-shirt that was
in the background of a scene in
spider-man 2 and they're like that's
totally Punisher because it looks so
kind of like Thomas Jane I don't know if
that's on purpose or not I don't think
so but I do like to believe that you got
a map and kill wait what
no bushwhackers the guy with the cane
he's Duke Nukem with the robot that's
right I got confused for a second there
that's like what why don't get a Max
Payne kill well I don't know but anyway
I like to believe that the daredevil
movie the Elektra movie The Punisher
2004 film the Sam Raimi spider-man
movies the 2005 Fantastic Four's and the
2003 Hulk movies are all their own
Marvel Cinematic Universe yes I like to
think that oh dude piranhas oh my god
now you're teaming up with the animals
uh he always has like the best
one-liners after him too I think it said
that that guy was actually Thomas being
stunt double I I didn't hear anything
about that but I did cos I've gotten
conflicting reports but I believe it
that guy look look like it
Donovan Parker here's a shout-out buddy
do you like rustling dude I like making
fun of wrestling like like Ric Flair in
his constant woes
well of course the daredevil Elektra
movie are connected just because they
took why not share our actors you know
but would you review Peter Jackson's
King Kong games I don't know is it good
yeah I remember that I think there's
like a first-person shooter Kong young
pre-placed a guy on stole island corn
bugs with the shotgun
we got a save John I don't put up with
this that guy's that guy's gonna get it
hey I figured out where to rest the
headphone wire that I can hear out of my
left side again yeah needs to be exactly
like this there's so many dudes to shoot
this is so weird of an area like this is
supposed to be a zoo right like what
exhibit was this I think they killed all
the animals too horrible
these bastards they hurt the animals
look around and see if you can find like
a deadline there's a lot of dead animals
around here
they're called the new cheese huh these
Cravens have fur
Ravens first hunt a good read um I can't
remember I don't think I read first time
I remember I read last time that one's
great I'm going to make the deme humans
character creator and Lego Marvel
superheroes - oh that's cool the Central
Park Zoo is nothing like this cuz
Diego's uh he's a firefighter in New
York
oh yeah apparently he was like I think
guy he was on standby on set for Gotham
once cuz actually cause he was also an
EMT and they get like real ambulances
for those yeah the a guy has a lot of
cool stuff going on just from being in
New York I I think his girlfriend was
also like on set for like daredevil I
think he said once
Marvel heroes is shutting down yeah this
the MMO Marvel game oh yeah well um
don't worry I think that that'll work
itself out in a fun way let's just say
that I've talked to one of the
developers for that game and he told me
something really cool about it getting
shut down so yeah because I I know folks
yeah oh dude sacrifice them on the
temple ah that's right
damn it you hit the wrong button did ya
I do that all the time oh wait oh we
gotta find another dude I'm already at
full health I know the headphones are
being bad again no damn E that's one
sacrifice I wanted to sacrifice that guy
in the blood altar there's actually a
thing that has like blood trails that
lead into a bucket that's because I get
it's so bizarre how long has the stream
been going on about an hour and a half
pretty sure actually what's your
favorite punish your story arc why is it
uh kill you in July is it welcome back
Frank I don't know I'm actually very
partial to up is down and black is white
from Punisher max yeah you saved him you
saved him you're such a hero
traumatized I wanna be just like you
when I grow up mr. Castle watch out
they're setting up a trapper on the
stone arch around the walkway Thanks now
get out of here
that guy is the voice of Deadpool in
Ultimate Alliance I could totally tell
Xavier is Cravens first not a good read
as I said a few seconds ago I don't know
I haven't read that one
but anyway Marvel heroes Omega from what
I've heard about it it's gonna be
alright because one of my biggest
problems with that game is how absurdly
expensive everything is that's
Bushwhacker don't shoot it Joan oh no he
lifted his hand up reaching for the sky
going
do you like MC use Flash Thompson I feel
like he is too nerdy and not believable
for being the badass agent venom no one
cares about Flash Thompson he's my
favorite spider-man side character no
one cares about him he will never be
agent venom and I'm super sad about you
just because I really love his character
arc of going from being a bully to being
a good guy if at first your friend
doesn't succeed try and do the exact
same thing he died doing yeah
oh yeah I did the fan art of you saying
I guess he wasn't the bomb squad walking
away from an explosion
I like that fan art I love fan art it's
like somewhat my favorite thing probably
about this is just the amount of fan art
I get so much of it and I say if I save
all of it cuz I want to try and put it
in videos like during the intros and go
I just hear some random fan art and then
like credit the person on Twitter who
sent it I love that stuff that's awesome
mr. waffle can I meme animals spelled
with a Z sure
Xavier what do you think about the
Gibbon
so what GI b bo n is that a character
that I'm forgetting I feel like that's a
comic-book character that I'm forgetting
who the hell that is
hey man you got a lot of grenades I do
I'm trying to get bad guy why's Monet no
it's okay we can't get past that artists
well you just let him like explode it
and then just not go under it just do
this no no I just like walk under it and
then just like it's one back no oh I'm
good I'm good okay I was gonna say like
hit the left trigger to uh just jump
back oh yeah Xavier I don't have a
Twitter to send you fan art or or a
discord is there any other way I can
send you stuff um not really that's
pretty much like the two primary ways I
mean I know there's some kind of like
messenger thing on like YouTube now but
I don't know exactly how it works if you
really don't want to get a discord or
Twitter you can probably try and do that
I'm not sure I honestly don't understand
the people that call spider-man
homecoming and sjw movie well cuz there
was two lines from one character who
said things that were like
of that nature and apparently the whole
movie is like that I guess for no reason
just because of those two lines gun
addresses Xavier on Halloween in 2018
you know actually my buddy Joey uh
dressed up as me for a party because he
tried to dye his hair and then it
accidentally turned red so then he got
some like thick rimmed glasses and put
on a bunch of Deadpool merch and then
just went to a party as me pretty good
have you seen Josh Keaton voicing over
the spider-man 60s memes oh yeah I love
those videos those are the best how do
you think what vulture or how do you
think Raimi would have handled vulture
in spider-man 3 how do you got the
chance I don't know I feel like you'd
try too hard to make him sympathetic I
feel like all Raimi tries a little bit
too hard to make all the villains
sympathetic look there's a dead lion
right next to you is there yeah turn
around behind that tree or a dead animal
of some kind oh yeah you're right
those bastards even for new cheese yeah
I guess it's so the player can't do it
because they know the player is a
sociopath for enjoying this game we have
to kill all the animals before they can
so this game doesn't seem too terrible
cuz this this is almost pushing to the
point of being hatred you know I just
[ __ ] hate so much my name is not
important if you press the trigger you
can throw your knife okay and it always
Auto targets so like it's just so stupid
how far and how accurate he can throw it
are you throwing it over a rock now yeah
yeah it's kind of hard to see what it's
like I feel like that's sitting yeah
that's like a balancing thing where you
get to overpowered so they put on a
filter that makes it harder to see you
can't see you I miss Bruce Campbell
cameo in spider-man movies and games
yeah wait I miss it too what the game
Bruce Campbell is in all three
spider-man movies he's the guy who uh
he's the announcer at the the wrestling
match
who says spider-man well he's like no
it's the human spider he goes spider-man
and he's all pissed yeah uh he's it he's
the the mean uh sure and spider-man -
that won't let him into the end of the
play and he's like telling him that he
can't go in in the middle of the thing
and then ask him for his ticket or
something yeah he's also the goofy
French waiter in spider-man 3 that puts
the ring in the wine that was oh yeah he
just had a fake mustache on you should
livestream splatterhouse next oh man I
want him no no that's a special
interrogation I think cuz he's got the
skull over his yeah
you gotta get over there and ask him
some questions Savior what do you think
of the Hellboy the Hellboy and old
Hellboy movies old Hellboy movies I only
really like the first one I think Golden
Army is kind of
Ron Perlman made a good morning oh boy
though I do think people are being
really closed-minded about the recasting
and not giving a what is a
David Harbor a chance because everyone
always always throws this really
obnoxious hissy fit every time they
recast the Supergirl character because
they go no man you can't do that Hellboy
is Ron Perlman they always say that this
actor is this character like just as US
hardline fact no man Andrew Garfield is
spider-man you can't change that
nah man Christian Bale is Batman no way
and it's the most obnoxious thing
because then they always are a bunch of
they always change their story as soon
as the movie comes out and it turns out
that the casting works and they're like
man I would I was on Ben Affleck side
from the start I don't know about the
rest of you I'm not gonna be a dick I'll
admit it I wasn't on board for Ben
Affleck fart for a while and then I saw
him in the movie and I went oh alright
he did an okay job know the new cheese
will kill me just like they killed all
those nah man Robert Downey jr. is Iron
Man you see the the thing that annoys me
about that close-minded thinking is that
that means that you'll never be able to
make another Iron Man movie ever again
if you just refuse every time someone
tries to recast the character there
it'll be 30 years and they'll be like
hey it's been a long time since we made
an Iron Man movie should we do another
one we could do like maybe one about
Mandarin or we could do like the armor
wars story or you know that have fing
Fang Foom like just whatever just
anything and you go no Robert Downey jr.
is now like seventy years old you can't
do it no lo you're not allowed to ever
have a no movie
Xavier is Godzilla Mendoza he imagine if
they tried to recast me likee she's one
day the YouTube channel started and just
like someone else do is just narrating
onto videos yeah but Robert Downey jr.
is Iron Man he said it 9 Man 3 remember
that's true he did say that um and at
the end of 1 Xavier what's better thor
ragnarok or Justice League I don't know
I haven't seen either of them I don't
have money to go to the movies a
favorite Batman game / movie probably
just Arkham Asylum which I plan on
finishing on on later streams but this
one it was just like a special thing
because the Netflix show coming out what
about Hugh Jackman is Wolverine do you
think anyone could replace him oh yeah
dude there's gonna be another actor
that'll come along and be perfect for
the party everyone's just like it was
they don't give anyone can
[Music]
yeah you did it you saved all the
hostage men and they're helping you now
yeah
friendship friendship friendship oh
shoot that guy and then interrogate his
buddy
oh is nards yeah yeah do that do that
yes it's a rhino
oh my god what what just happened all
right you're out of ten hey Xavier
what's your favorite favorite symbiote
besides venom - toxin Punisher loves
animals Tom Hardy would be an awesome
Wolverine I don't know I feel like
everyone's snap judges - Tom Hardy on
every time they want to cast I love Tom
Hardy but can't do it when they were
like hey the rights to punisher have
reverted back to marvel like after
punisher warzone was a flop and then
everyone went Tom Hardy Tom Hardy time
re time RT was like now now and then and
then of course they're like hey we have
like here's like six different
characters and Suicide Squad everyone's
booked Tom Hardy Tom Hardy Tom are you
there like well you can be Rick Flagg
he's like why would I want to be this
boring nothing character who isn't only
like 20 minutes of the movie Savior
what's your thoughts on the first lego
marvel movies oh I love it
Lego Avengers however is an unworthy
sequel because it's just a giant
commercial for the MCU quick Savior your
security guard grows no
I'm working on Xavier is getting recast
and cletus kasady from the amazing
spider-man 2 game
oh you mean Dexter Al Pacino equals toni
cipriani John will have Bernthal and
make a good Wolverine I think yeah I see
that sometimes too I think there's a
couple of things that he said and cuz
they they try to make him less of like a
stoic like like super ultra
narrow-minded badass like just cuz like
Frank Castle is typically portrayed is
just like being the most inhuman
character but they try to give him a
couple of moments where he's a little
bit less like robot II in the Netflix
show and he says some stuff that's that
sounds kind of like stuff Wolverine
would say hey Xavier what situation
would you rather be in locked in the
room with carnage or locked in the room
with the Joker well I feel like the
Joker would have a long monologue first
while I was carving through it probably
just like pull my nose yeah well my
intestines out through my ears sometimes
I see too much Shane Walsh than Frank
Castle but they're extremely different
personalities you know cuz Shane Walsh
is this this really selfish
self-absorbed guy you know what's great
about Jon Bernthal casting this is Shane
and The Walking Dead is that he did so
well at being this this just scumbag
Tara character that for like a whole
solid year after Shane died on Walking
Dead
I still got angry at Jon Bernthal every
time I saw like I saw his face and I
said oh it's bad
well I casing board oh no that was an
interrogation ah yeah you gotta count
another okay hold on oh there's like
several of them
oh wait how long ago did you enter this
spot just like restart or right now I
just kill these guys here's one guy do
do the thing gotta get him well no
there's two two different invents two
different things I want to try them both
use that guy how do I go over and grab
them and then just drag him back okay
all right take him over there I I take
him to the other one on the balcony
don't active yeah all right let's see
what this one is all right I think this
one might be the disappointing one
Pleasant there we go yeah yeah tell me
nothing you don't say we knew that you
you deserve to get penguin a fight what
happens
he just bashed his head and he fell down
into the penguin exhibit oh and then
look look at the Penguins is chilling
out look look to your left
oh yeah they're just just hanging
I wanted to eat them and they're just a
vicious swarm of penguins just come
thanks for waiting for it that'll get
you a cool wash oh those electric eels
Xavier I went to go to your discord and
it said be careful this site may be
harmful the site I don't know anything
about that man it's the same link I've
always had for the discord and other
people have been able to use it that's a
little weird
some discord links have been broken with
some discord links have been broken
yeah I might have to put a new one in
the description gay meant you might have
to get ah darn castle that's in general
I haven't read lately
someone with a hard to say first name TJ
a wide this is TJ hold stop yes yours
reboot shout out tangu versus Frank
Castle the greatest crossover is your
favorite non Supergirl graphic novel
I a lot well I mean I don't know if
Luther strode counts because it does
have a character that's super strong but
it's like not really a super you know
thing I really like this this series
called baby teeth which is about a girl
who gives birth to the Antichrist and
she's like in high school and she's just
trying her hardest to just get get it
get it get by she's just really stressed
out okay she's gotta like she's been her
baby only drinks blood she's just gotta
like she's hooked up to an IV and she's
like ah man it's hard going to high
school and being a teen mom also when
your son is the Antichrist and there's
like assassins from like a religious
group that wanted want to kill it and
save the world
but she's like come on no it's only a
baby how much how much moon night should
be given a tv-series I want them to but
I feel like they'd screw it up if you
could choose anyone to be a Spider Man
Oh God
if you could choose anyone to be a
Spider Man any actor or voice actor who
to be I always feel like spider-man
would be interesting Elise if he was
voiced by Elijah Wood
for some reason sometimes I read
spider-man dialogue and I hear it in
Elijah Wood voice I don't know I just
found will always wondered what that
would sound like hey if you watched the
ticke 2017 it talks about topics of
insanity slash mental illness which
seems like a tiny thing oh yeah insanity
and mental illness definitely is my
thing find my face kind of my that's my
kind of bad I haven't watched the new
tic series but I definitely want to I'm
gonna try and bomb an Amazon account off
of David so I could watch it have you
played puppet I know I I'm not cool
enough for that excuse you awesome head
cool face Xavier is more than a
human-shaped meat he is personal he has
the first thing yeah
Donovan Parker can I get another
shoutout uh no no no you only get one
the choke bat is that technically that
was one no no no no it doesn't was it
would you basically say shout out to
shout out to this person who will not be
shout out to Maria castle for motivating
one of the coolest comic book characters
she's the real MVP like you know a Frank
if it wasn't for Maria Frank would be a
lot more boring kill to kill or all the
dudes okay you gotta stop the bronze
from eating Joan Sam Joan yeah throw
your knives yeah climb out are you
running around stabbing dudes I think
there's dudes on this level too haha I
can't I can't see it's so hard to see oh
I could see I could see I'm going blind
climb up the ladder oh yeah yeah freedom
Nightwing versus daredevil probably
daredevil just because he has the
advantage of the powers oh well know ah
I gotta get another one
[Music]
grab that one grab this guy visible okay
this one find someone to kill I got it
oh geez hang on Joan I got to do this
thing first hopefully she's in peril and
there's a time limit and you're
torturing guys for information
it's totally Nestor where's Joan right
there right there where is she right
there where is June all right John I
just wanted to demonstrate what would
happen to go to turn the switch where is
the credits right there oh oh oh no we
were really banking on that working
what's in there yeah um quick kill all
the piranhas that's easy yeah just start
shooting oh [ __ ] all right
oh no hang on Joan I'll figure this out
this is not going well
David you hear that axel Alonso was out
of Marvel I yes indeed I'm quite happy
about that Oh
[Music]
um shoot this shoot the controls to
shoot it it was dead when things don't
work just shoot it what's in there
get off valve quick kill we're good yeah
don't escape go live on a farm and be
happy okay oh I'm so sorry Joe I should
have I should have probably prioritized
my time a little better but now let's
see if she's the movie version which is
just a normal girl or if she's the mousy
one he'll be dead soon
the comic version okay gdm 245 Xavier
thanks for the shout on in your
spider-man stream well here's another
one
mr. Godzilla how was your day well I
woke up um I slept in I did some chores
and cleaned up the house a little bit
and then uh Jackson got here and then we
started streaming yeah we cut up clothes
hey do you think V for Vendetta Vendetta
is a criminally underrated movie I don't
know man I feel like everyone knows what
that movie is everyone I mean why do you
anyway I don't I said okay a lot of
people know about the movie it's just I
don't really hear them say anything
positive or negative about it they say
yeah yeah I saw it it's the thing that
exists yeah um I don't know I didn't
have like the greatest time with it I
think I enjoyed reading the comic more
is that but that's just me if you could
go to the timeline where Nic Cage with
Superman would you boy would I you know
I want to go to all to all the alternate
timelines where these supposed almost
castings happened then just buy a DVD
and then keep it in business right back
here's my Superman is Nick a funny you
here's my Lido's and by the way these
are all real yeah here's my Superman is
Nic Cage here's my Jim from the office
as Captain America here's my Michael
Jackson his spider-man Oh dad that one I
ways you tried to buy his own
Marvel so he can make it happen so just
so I could be there he was so excited he
made himself white and now that was the
only reason that was the O'Leary's yeah
did you read the Batman and Punisher
crossover comic I kind of skimmed
through it I didn't actually sit down to
really read it read it
let's increase our accuracy so we can um
yeah cuz because we really need to buy
we need to help with that yeah will you
ever stream edge of time yeah man I mean
if people are interested that'd be fun
what's the yeah oh yeah yeah oh man I
hope it's the polar bear thing um what
was it
export journal okay let's see Punisher
kills innocent animals yeah that's from
it's a screenshot from welcome back
Frank oh they're so happy oh hello sir
did you like Thor three haven't seen it
yet Thomas Johnson I plan to soon Savior
did you hear that they're making a
Deadpool cartoon next year yeah and
Donald Glover is gonna be one of the
writers and producers Disney were
actually offended by EA's implementation
of the micro transactions in Battlefront
2 hopefully they take the rights back
from them and after this situation man I
hope so
I after battlefront won cuz that that
base game has like formats it's got
nothing in it yeah there's it's just so
stripped for content I felt cheated when
I spent $60 on that like that's that's
one of the reasons I'm so hesitant to
buy video games anymore is cause like
one I have way less money now than I did
back in 2015 it was only cuz like
earlier this year because he saw like
some battlefront two tennis three other
games coming out oh my god there's a lot
of good games man that's Roman again
it's Bobby's funeral today what's he
gonna do what's he gonna do I want you
to guess how this mission
gonna start hopefully pops out of the
casket
if he doesn't pop out of the cab he
doesn't pop out of the casket shooting
everyone it'll be a bad game look at
this game a bad gray or out of Ted so
now you're going head to head with the
new Qi crime syndicate you hit there
yeah man running operations in the Chop
Shop then you track alleged you found
the drugs there yeah
don't tell me alleged beefs mom for some
reason so she had Bushwhacker grab your
friend Joan and lead you a merry chase
through the Central Zoo yes I just saw
both of those things thank you for
telling me
most people crash parties you crash
funerals but I guess for you Frank
Xavier favorite GTA game um I don't know
I only really played four and five I
didn't get to play the other ones
Oh see you Andre it was good having you
here all new t clans gathering for
Bobby's funeral should we bring in
Bobby's casket now show some respect
[Music]
cuz the rigor mortis he's all like hard
to move
I mean he's face though like yeah that
was funeral fit for an uchi nuraghe
Shetty says can you give me a shout-out
I don't know how to pronounce everyone's
name shipping coke and Bobby's box
why is he still have his sunglasses on
yeah why didn't Bobby still have glasses
sunglasses a good point so he looked
cool when he goes to hell go to the
mansion torture those two guys in the
basement and you'll feel better
Xavier what's a weird fact about
yourself um um I I thought I got my
first job when I was like eight years
old but it turns out I didn't my aunt
worked at a comic book shop and my mom
told her hey can you just let him hang
out behind the desk for a few hours
maybe just grade some comics like put
the stickers on him and then uh and then
you know at the end of the day my mom
gave me gave my aunt 20 bucks to give me
and then I thought I had a job and it
was just my mom just wanted me to have
something fun to do on the weekends so
yeah ah the recoil is so bad on this I'm
shooting at the ceiling now yeah oh it's
been so long since I played I'm so
excited to be back
[Music]
there's another one with the
flamethrower that's really great ah it's
okay girlby
there'll be other interrogate special
kill David interrogation is the kill
it's a grenade
ah dude special interrogation okay like
everyone sat around watching in fear
everyone was still freaked out they
didn't know what to do
wait no no no no shield chill chill I
want one yeah I'm such a bad man meme
game oh I feel so bad like I feel like a
bad person for loving wait no no no no
she'll kill ya what a lot of really nice
caskets getting ruined here oh yeah
Punisher is just such a bastard he
doesn't think about my funeral home all
of their special gold caskets just
exploded special interrogation oh my god
she's heavy
aha
Oh on alright I have a question for you
sir
talk word mine hey stop it
yeah yeah the Max Payne I think it's
just cuz it was the last guy but it's
that doesn't make any sense
can I do the special interrogation here
or do it does it just just kill him at
any price okay well I'll just did
interrogate him over I got to find a
good spot I like the lighting in this
corner the corner corner is pretty
elegant I like the the urns you know
ashes to ashes sort of symbolism yeah
yeah all right how do i okay
I forgot how to do yeah punish him okay
oh yeah you died in a really a really
nice corner of the room yeah exactly
uh let's see what else remember that one
time a demon attached itself to spun
asure and grew more powerful with every
person Frank killed oh yeah
in the demon's face actually looks like
the skull logo and the reasons Frank
picked the logo is because it's being
subtle young
which was actually the damn soul of the
first crime boss and killed
actually pretty cool yeah and then and
then uh and then heaven found Punisher
and were like we need you to kill this
demon boy who do best and he's like but
I don't got guns that can kill no demon
so I gave him to heaven powered Aziz
that I fooled by the souls of dead
criminals and and they they fired
they were like plasma Aziz and he was
basically running around just killing
demons and he was like a Ghostbuster oh
wait was that the goat that was that yes
yeah they'll say doesn't sound that bad
maybe a bit more out later
ah I mean there's that one time Punisher
became Frankenstein oh yeah I hate that
pun more than any Franken Castle Frank
and Casilla is way better than it had
any right to be because it was both very
well written it had a lot of cool stuff
in it and the the art by Tony Moore was
really awesome like there it's so stupid
and aggravates me so much that I love
Franken Castle heaven powered Newsies
holy [ __ ] I need to start reading The
Punisher everyone needs to read Punisher
like of cool characters there's there's
spider-man and then there's Punisher and
then there's like midnight those are all
some of my favorites you can tell I
really really love a character just
based on if I have a tattoo of them
that's why I want to get a moon night
tattoos because he's like fullback yeah
oh oh we got it we on Terry ashes give
up whatever your name is it's still one
guy there's still guy where is he
somewhere I got really gained your left
yeah there you go yeah hit man versus
Punisher well they'd uh you see hit man
would do this kind of stuff like without
the interrogation part Punisher and
Terramax gates ah ah so so he's gonna
cremate him okay so you got it turn the
knob to see ya oh my god
oh my god there's okay you said that
there's a boiler where what this is a
kitchen I think so where should I start
reading The Punisher just start it like
mm the first Garth Ennis run welcome
back Frank which is a Marvel night two
Punisher start there and then just catch
up till now because I think those are
all the best ones the one is based on
Punisher max and mixed with Punisher
welcome back with a little bit of hints
of like some of the earlier story
stories the introduce a character like
micro it's a little bit all over the
place but mostly Punisher max Punisher
max isn't a separate continuity you
don't have to meet it but it's the best
Punisher stories are in Punisher max so
started Punisher max number one and
basically just look for any Punisher
story written by Garth Ennis I blew up
their drugs but I still need to find
Eddie oh man the fumes in that room
would probably get you so messed up
[Music]
some of the music is just like yeah yeah
music is just so classy yeah yeah
accurate assessment
alright get out of here you crazy guy oh
dude it is bass on the corner
ah I'll kill you after that just so your
jaw doesn't hurt anymore
cuz I brought heat man that guy is gonna
have so I saved him so much money on
dental bills
this funeral row home has a lot of drugs
and crime boxes okay you get a special
one we need to get some new guns we do
favorite superhero soundtrack I really
like the soundtrack and x-men three but
also I really like the one from Man of
Steel do you like the Dark Knight's evil
Batman comic I haven't been able to get
to that one yet um well I got a scroll
up there are some questions hey Xavier
have you read the Batman adventures if
so what are your thoughts
I haven't read Batman adventures sadly I
haven't read a lot of Batman comics I
really like to hear that for boy reason
read more of them but I hate used to
having that time it's you
don't shoot I'm the mortician I own this
establishment
I'd like to thank you Frank Reynolds
this makeup over that play for the years
or no is the beauty hang work has put my
three kids through college that's so
awesome
dude I love that that's the dumbest lord
man there's just a guy huh mortician
assist booming there's a mortician who
just makes a ton of money from Frank
castles existence
oh yeah I'm gonna hear all that I'll
help you out buddy
man you know what
yeah I feel good about all the punishing
because I'm helping society but I also
feel good because that guy is just
having a much easier time you know he
probably can afford his house because of
the Punisher oh well I got lifts the
dude up and shoots him it's it's just so
cool he's trying to run back come back
you're gonna get ad oh oh is nethers
have you read Moon Knight 188 yes the
new one that just came out I like it
um it's given me some crossed vibes but
it's really cool um I like I like the
villain they are setting up right now
he's really interesting Halong is all
that's keeping you alive yeah I'm such a
hero yeah no wait here til the police
arrive
do you like South Park I mean yeah I've
watched pretty much every episode at one
point or another
oh yeah sure I'm gonna interrogate this
guy to death right in front of this
traumatized woman who else is between us
we gotta make sure we got to make sure
to be a really cool one I'm worried
there's just indeed no no no no no no no
no no no yeah we scouts interrogator
okay I'm gonna interrogate you in this
room sir okay all right
hello madam III decided I want to punch
him I want to UM I want to put my gun I
might do the gun attention yeah yeah
Otto gosh Wow
whoops oops while I was trying to get
him to talk but he wasn't going for it
you know and he he went to grab my gun
you saw it sets a pistol down next to
his body self defense
hey do you live in Colorado just
wondering cuz I do well there's a reason
I go to Denver Comic Con so much I'll
tell you that it's cuz we live in Sandy
because we live in San Diego right next
door to Denver you've been to San Diego
Colorado it's lovely do you think a
Marvel and fighting game like injustice
could work yeah maybe I mean you know
it'd be really cool as it's like there's
like a Marvel fighting game that like
crossed over look like a different
franchise like like maybe like a whole
video game company like Marvel vs. like
God you know I think there's a game
series kind of like that that'll be
interesting yeah yeah yeah there's just
nothing like that yeah you think have
you seen the Deadpool 2 teaser yeah I
have I mix I'm just waiting for the
one-liner
[Music]
taking a really long time damn it no
tell me useful information so I can do
this cool thing yeah they are they're
like making it harder so I can't like
calibrate the amount that I'm dammit all
right what are you is gonna have to take
his place who's the lucky winner all
right let's go let's go has go hang out
some of those ivory keys go on let's go
let's go play us a little song huh
you know you interested oh wait is that
another Galton yes yeah okay not the
lucky winner today I'll get you instead
all right I have to always kind of pause
and make sure I hit the right button
what was my favorite spider-man villain
venom Frank hitting him on the head and
him barely reacting was pretty hilarious
ice guy he's got really too high paint
wrong stuff dude
[Music]
yeah won't tell me what I wanna know
okay all right thank you
what's a good what's a good pun related
to this I'm just ready music to my ears
Oh someone said that in the chat there
we go oh yeah I love them they're the
best alright so yeah secret door secret
door secret door secret door secret door
secret door this morning asked to
explain why he has all these secret
doors secret door oh man we skipped some
areas they have probably missed a gun
Wow um there's a legit kid who goes to
my school and wears the Deadpool hoodie
and I had to do a tough a double take
there's a lot of people who are dead for
design it's like saying like you saw a
guy wearing a black shirt and you were
like oh my god it's Jason Bourne
come on full thin full costume
impressive yeah that's that's how you
know it's me yeah Eddie Nucci where are
you at
I have some questions to ask you I have
engraved them on all of the individual
pellets in this shotgun shell because
it's a lot of questions
we have any grenades that's a no ah that
knife one is always there just the most
unpleasant to look at oh man
Punisher knows a lot of really amazing
horrible ways to do this stuff oh you
got me she got him have you read any of
Punisher max Jackson you have to dude
that is some of the best comic writing
I've ever seen and that series is just
so awesome I'll send you a couple of
mine um that's definitely something you
should check out like the first arc has
this really great scene where Punisher
his role as a guy out of a we know and
he lands on a fence post which they they
kind of like tried to use for war zone
but then that guy breaks the fence post
like he's got like a whole like four
foot section of fence still stuck in him
and he walked he's walking around with
it and punish her sees him and because
that book is uncensored it just says you
gotta be [ __ ] kidding me
and then Punisher shoots him in the face
and it just is like that better stop him
and it just cuts to the guy's face it's
just just like exploding it like blown
out goal of shotgun favorite horror
movie the thing in 1982 by John Hartman
it's a great movie where is Eddie Nucci
I can't tell I can't I've done some
damage to him apparently they everyone
looks the same here everyone looks like
Anna dinner a mafioso with a brown
bomber jacket Erin's got brown bomber
jackets and dark colored hair so in like
blue pants probably everyone's dressed
like Nico Bellic
the exactly
now you Freddy Nucci are you ready Nucci
who's Eddie Nucci raise of hands is this
like a Spartacus thing oh man
Eddie note G is that him I think I saw
something out of the corner of my eye
this way so there's so many Italian
people in here then yeah yeah he's the
one with the special Johnny oh my god
yeah go under each boat
yeah I'm gonna get him where is he
guy throw that at him mercy right where
are you I you bastard my family Maria
mr. Hewett I can't see I know it's so
dark it's so difficult
ah there you are
at least he's not dying in a super
unreasonable rate you know I get thought
that wasn't for second places that die
and raise the rate dies dead just falls
down wait tonight am I out of guns yeah
thank you
oh my god all right I guess I'll have to
do this the old-fashioned way
damage she's gonna stand there I'll
shake you in a prison and then Adam oh
we can't do that no nothing all right
okay then guess I'll just use both of
these even though that's let's do it
once again
Punisher hates m16s I think he actually
I think called it a plastic piece of
[ __ ] because of the Vietnam background
stuff you know in punisher max it was
awesome he uses an a k is that one's
sturdy and wooden man listen own to jam
a lot do though at least a on how rich
they are yeah yeah hey do any of you
guys know where Eddie is Eddie new chief
he's too looks exactly like you but in a
slightly different shirt blue suit it's
the only difference Eddie I need my boy
don't make me turn up the brightness so
it's easier to find you I'll do it
behind you Izzy this is true sir I can't
not I can't aim worth a [ __ ] but still I
I don't need to it's a shotgun that I've
been using is it yeah
there you is
Eddie I have some questions for you the
main one being why won't you die damn it
no you Oh up still damn it
don't tell me to hold still damn it when
you're the one who needs to hold still
damn it oh wow that lasted not long time
seconds like it was even even use mad
but he wasn't forgot how you get extra
health in this game oh gosh coz I'm
getting close to death yes we are their
health pack that we've just been not
even seeing I didn't even get room I
think it goes back over time yeah stop
going down the stairs it's harder to
find you when you do that oh my god I'm
just chasing him around in circles up
there up and down this flight of stairs
three much Eddie my knees hurt I'm gonna
take it out on your knees where yeah
there you are right is that no that was
doing oh my gosh haha
I think the blue suits just camouflage
yeah we're we need four more brightness
for this there you go
I like this comment this should this
video should be called Xavier cries
about how perfect punisher max is yeah
it's quality at least well punisher max
gets a lot less good as soon as guard
Hannah stop right it's just gonna rate
suddenly Marvel's just gonna get a big
boost in sailing Punisher mags or piracy
sites are one of the two a little column
a a little anomaly and a stopover this
appears is the Chris Burke and he
disappears into the night like the
Batman yeah
that's doing that I can't get him my
controls are reversed are you serious
yeah it was weird that was also me
what's your favorite I quite enjoyed
Punisher
Remax okay ready yeah they're spreading
the Punisher gone for running the pasta
the gospel at one point make a cat
making a Captain America videogame that
one's Sega make would be a good idea it
may be like an Avenger game
retrospective so you can talk about the
whole games too I guess okay we're gonna
interrogate yeah Garth Ennis loves his
own stories so he's just constantly rips
them off for this game yeah oh boy that
was real satisfying Punishers crashes a
funeral home oh yeah yeah Punisher
murders everyone at normal person funnel
Punisher massacres funeral homes let's
see news clippings Punisher disguises
self as Corpse strange new fetish mob
funeral becomes miss well that one's a
good title that is a quality title yeah
how'd they get that picture of me
choking a guy dedicated so no one is
going to mention Incredibles - oh yeah
the trailer for Incredibles 2 came out
yeah I haven't seen either
um no Xavier you got it all wrong the
video game should be called the
family-friendly game night this is the
most family-friendly game absolutely
alright well will shut down the harbor
and then we'll be that'll be it for
today's stream and then maybe we can try
this route playing more of the same
again lady shouldn't mercenary syndicate
I'm gonna cut the flow off at the
harbour a Russian mercenary syndicated
alright alright
I'm down what happened to mom we haven't
seen Manucci yet are gonna
trust me we'll get to her the new Chi
drug operations alright yeah with the
proper application of bullets said the
drugs stopped flowing did they Castle
the new Chi said other ways again in
just no they did not see something out
onto the streets it's just like Ulysses
fighting that lion and Roman legend chop
off one head and two more appear soap
that's Hercules fighting the Hydra and
it's a Greek legend
let's fight Hydra hail Hydra oh you
decided to investigate the docks for
yourself
oh boy Dane I'm excited I know who's all
its we're so close to a new girl a girl
shows up and helps us while we're
fighting the Russian mercenaries how
could that possibly be all right let's
go
the Russians should run the subway
system hail Hydra do you like the DP
teaser did you get to parody of course I
got the parody everyone knows who Bob
Ross is I fall asleep to Bob Ross clips
on Netflix there you are a dumbass Yuri
I can hear you oh I should have done
that the other guy fell he fell over the
ledge into the water we kind of got it
kind of did it
Xavier did you think what do you think
of Frank Castle getting the war machine
armor I'm annoyed that they keep calling
him war machine out like that's his new
name all of a sudden that's stupid
James Rome Rhett James Rhodes is war
machine like stop it just because I he's
wearing an Iron Man suit does not mean
he's war machine okay
just like war machine wearing an Iron
Man suit does not make him Iron Men
except that one time that James Rhodes
was Iron Man for a little while
during Secret Wars but still stop
changing names just call him what he is
he's the Punisher he's just wearing an
Iron Man suit now which is kind of funny
considering what direction this game
goes this is where you tell me
everything you know I know nothing
okay bye
ah he hits his face on it and then drops
in this is a catch-and-release dock Oh
where's the grenades he said there were
grenade stones Oh under a dumpster I
think over there so there's some
grenades under this copy of destiny Oh
oh I'm sorry I lost subscribers is now
alright
is this a door I can kick in or where do
I go is this alright yeah yeah alright
let's do it haha jump to his dad yes he
just jumped and he didn't make it
what a dumbass no like you like that
one-liner there what on earth I threw a
flashbang
yeah yeah the good guns here we go now
it's canonically correct stop ruining
this I'm gonna interrogate this guy you
can't stop me that's a really good shot
oh hey Xavier who do you think will be
doing it or do you think you'll be doing
a big one our review for spider-man ps4
is simple maybe oh my god
she's in the restaurant okay thanks
every time he has something to say
oh wow the kickback on that is really
hard there's a lot of recoil at least it
won't chance Lisa won't Jam constantly
or explode like the samsung note rifle 7
which is with the m16 right hand sport
that's what that means all right the
Intel rifle look everyone I'm using a a
survival knives King easily
this is especially funny since neither
of us know anything about guns
haha yeah now he's sleeping with the
fishes
Oh is the best you're going with them
this isn't killing anyone it's probably
not
Varane infested waters piranha-infested
Hudson Bay everyone knows that New York
is just like this warmer nor yeah in
fact they've become a delicacy people in
New York eat like 90% piranhas just
because there's so many of them
oh yeah resources yeah
where while ago I there's the restaurant
at the end of the pier there
get him such a classic healing dialogue
came in picked up a guy shot him in the
chest and then dropped him yeah oh dude
he was eat him in the in the in the oh
how my brains I didn't know I needed I
didn't know I needed this [ __ ] in my
life until now rocks rock steady do that
[ __ ] hey Xavier Star Wars or Star Trek
um uh okay wait don't tell me you've run
the subway system
oh man that checkpoint is so rough start
damn dude they set us a ways back oh
gosh that's rough I know that voice what
was that hey who cares as long as
they're not shooting at us you are a
dumbass Yuri right here throw me I can
explain
alright now you're gonna you're gonna
give me information oh I hit the wrong
button damn it I was gonna Tara gate you
close that door
have I read any have you read any TMNT
games what have you read any TMNT games
I mean I'm supposed to plan mmm I don't
read a lot of videogame Oh have you read
any TMNT comics not really no I just
know that crazy stuff happens and I'm
like Donatello gets one of them gets a
robot arm I think it's Donatello any
Raph becomes like a cyborg one of them
dies
[Music]
okay all right tell me about the
grenades again and all that okay all
right cool thank you that's much
appreciated all right yeah this is a
kitchen David did you like the
spider-man Clone Saga I've talked a lot
about this in the past
Hank the Clone Saga there's some cool
ideas in terms of storytelling
but boy do they sure flub that delivery
come out but these are flash bangs I
want to explode people boy this game
really does just breathe really really
violent people yeah I didn't shoot at
that yeah at that guy this time that guy
just fell like an idiot Fox News is
right when they say it's just this one
this video this specific video only um
every time a mass shooting has happened
it's because someone played this game
you know you could play GTA all you want
doesn't cause I think this game just
nothing but you destroy us all
I love the under the dumpster guy oh
yeah he's my favorite character Black
Widow my favorite favorite superhero
animated TV show guy under the dumpster
guy the animated series ah I gotta say I
really like spectacular spider-man hold
on
hey not your head stand in another no no
my battery my assault and battery oh I
feel bad now it's a good thing that
we're almost done cuz his battery's
gonna die this battery's gonna do a
plain Stacy impression just to remember
everyone a part of the point of this
stream was to maybe see if we could
raise some cash to grab a copy of Lego
Marvel superheroes to all donations are
appreciated you can go check out my
patreon which is listed up there I think
it's also in the description and you'd
also if you don't want to send anything
that's alright - ah oh boy I hope you
don't get set way back of your damn it
how's college Xavier odds are it's
alright it's College are you playing
this on ps3 do you have this the four
USB port one yeah the really really old
one run this I have that it's a very
reliable console it only broke once
while i was playing dead space 3 because
i think it loved me too much to let me
finish that game the ps3 tried to save
me
yeah
alright let's try and speed on my crappy
ending it's a chicken the entire game
alright let's just go through this quick
no more screwing around
that's cool roll the whole way everyone
tactical rolling no no torture no
torture just yeah we're gonna kill the
enemy nothing else yeah don't do
anything to their nether regions if you
read Punisher born also in the max
timeline you know what I'm done boy was
that a dark
ah I loved I just I can't get over let's
do the brain one that's so bad but the
knife it's it's so horrible
ah in the mouth it's so bad kill them
all
Rustin piece monetization these channels
getting taken down for playing such a
violent game go on come on give me a
second guys I like how everyone in the
comments is just saying things is
overrated yeah someone sets like
something said it earlier and now it's
becoming the mean well yeah water is
overrated
it's why Xavier Leon dr. pepper yeah my
body is actually 80% dr. pepper this is
a really hard section mm-hmm damn it
here Jackson you try it while I just
talk okay I'll give it a shot
we're gonna get over it we're gonna get
through this we're almost at the
three-hour mark saying overrated is
overrated man I didn't know David had so
many alters this is impressive I just
keep switching through them so quickly
here let me I'm sure people started uh
promoting this thing on Twitter let's go
check that out
you're better than me at most video
games you should be great at this I mean
I think it's just cuz it's older so it's
kind of like yeah it's a little bit
stiffer yeah yeah it still plays really
I was playing Wolverines revenge the
other day and boy is that game really
stiff and hard to play
I barely play that game it's it's like
eventually you get used to the controls
and it's alright but still just like you
have to press a button to make your
claws come out in that game yeah and
that I don't like that
okay I'm retweeting all the people who
are promoting the link on Twitter to get
more people in here huh what hold on
it's our two
all right
yeah yeah do that
that will help throw the knives yeah we
could have we could have probably done
more I like how that guy's still reeling
in pain from the knife wound there's
people still going for the overrating um
dagger can I send you something over
discord I joined your server yeah man
don't worry about it said send me stuff
people send me stuff on discord all the
time
save your thoughts on the Deadpool 2
trailer I really hope this movie has a
script and is not just okay Ryan
Reynolds you're in the costume just say
something funny
like I want them to have actual Jodl
written into it because there's a lot of
times where it's really easy to tell
between a clever Deadpool joke and
here's the thing Ryan Reynolds said on
set they thought it was funny enough
that they left it in the shot cuz Ryan
Reynolds jokes are very very often
really easy and really not that
complicated like where he just goes holy
[ __ ] I am high alright yeah alright but
then when you get a clever joke where
they like doing that whole thing whether
we're hitting a blind owl or arguing
over like different types of IKEA
furniture yeah and they're like naming
off specific brands of furniture the
whole time and it's getting like really
slightly like strangely specific and
it's weird that they know all these
different furniture names that's funny
but then other times it's like Ryan
Reynolds just threw in some kind of
comment about masturbating
one of the action scenes sometimes The
Improv hits and it's it's a funny joke
sometimes it lands sometimes I think it
just really just kind of got like makes
me roll my eyes and go it come on you
could have caught you could have come up
with some funny here there my role mater
is underrated oh god no that's a writer
not Ike Perlmutter maybe make maybe Ike
Perlmutter decided that Punisher should
be Wolverine should be war war machine
oh dude dude this is gonna be awesome
make it quick it's scary
come on it's that it's the right stick
oh my god
up and down yeah right on it do you pull
on it and just hold it back or push it
forward and hold it forward okay let me
try you get you get this
I don't know like oh so you got to shake
it oh yeah shake it oh my god oh oh it's
like we're not we're not going back it's
no we can't accept it Oh
for justice I can't believe it
I think we're hopefully past a
checkpoint now but hopefully I really
hope so mana sure is a good Christian
role model one-time Punisher busted a
couple who were like filming like like
adult videos
oh no that he found a couple who were
filming adult videos with their kids in
their basement and he busted in and they
did they thought he was a cop at first
and then he made them walk him down to
the basement which is like this creepy
dungeon basement with a camera and a bed
and then he opens up his jacket and they
see the skull and they go oh you're not
a cop and then he murders both of them
and then he gets there and got damaged
oh this is one of those ones I do
off-screen and then and then he gets up
there and then calls social services to
pick up the kids and he sees out like
the dead look in their eyes and he goes
sometimes I'd like to get my hands on
God
that's that's the most that's the
awkward sex ever that's a good question
that's a good no comment what's the Big
Cheese great citizens we know lays
across the street all right do you think
we should end the stream about here yeah
I mean it's been a great time everyone
we had a fantastic time talking with
y'all and Ian really really mean to
climb you cannot but are they coming can
you stream Ultimate Alliance ps4 one day
it has online multiplayer you know I
might find some people to play that with
and try that out that'd be fun please
review the blade movie tie-in games
I would like to I've just like with this
game it's hard to find copies of that
stuff let's interrogate this guy this is
not Kyle by the way by Xavier and Kyle
this is a different guy this is Josh
yeah sure does Cam David back from
Nebraska
yeah David you sound different I know
but oh let me ask what's your opinion of
Star Wars it's overrated see that's how
you know
all righty then
well I was a pretty successful punished
man crusade in celebration of Netflix my
name is not important this is the
beginning of my genocides crusade
it's just fuzzy look I just fuzzy love
this world so much it's time for me to
care it's time for me to hug all right I
have a great time everyone it's been a
great it's been great you've all been a
lovely audience and we'd love to do this
again with you sometime soon see you
around
hold on I got to do something really
excessive and stupid for the very
endless